showed that i had a non-displaced
fracture in my wrist it was small but it
was still still yeah it had shown that
the bone that grew over it so it healed
i was still in pain because i kept
getting hit or falling on it so like i
guess i played with like somewhat of a
fracture for like two months and then in
the playoffs there was a play against
the walk in game three i dunked it
giannis chased me down and he fouled me
and i fell into like the crowd and that
was the most painful it's been since
that day that i heard it and i ended up
getting a cortisone shot in my wrist
that night and you could see it yeah
it's like much lighter i've lost like
color in my hand because it kills the
fat cells and there's not a lot of fat
in my hand you know after each game i
would have to like wear a brace you know
to shoot around and i would take it off
before the camera saw me then pre-game
taking my nap but i have to put it back
on you know just to make sure it was
stable so no one knew besides like
internally yeah it saw the team yeah in
my mind if i'm going out there to play
it's like nothing matters everybody's
banged up a little hurt you know if
you're injured then you can't play but
that was my whole reason of i was scared
to get an mri because i was like
something is wrong but like i don't want
anybody to tell me i can't play